the Joe Rogan experience its perceived
enemies that anyone late anybody with a
gun that's the whole thing you know if
you have a gun
you're not very intelligent why is that
because you're a paranoid you win if you
have a gun you're not intelligent
because you're paranoid
having a gun means that you're afraid
that someone's going to come in and
attack you mm-hmm you know right and and
so that having a gun is like like they
want to arm teachers for instance do not
seem categorizing yeah that is so stupid
it is so dumb right you know and just
like the ones that know know about guns
like the cops that didn't go into the
school the guy's got a a K yeah they're
not going to go into that school with
their little pistols and so they didn't
go into the school and the ones that
rushed a guide they ended up dying so
what I'm saying is that if you if you
have a gun and you if you think you need
a gun for your house for whatever if you
think you have something that's worth
someone else's life then you are
ignorant well I don't necessarily think
that's what they think they don't think
that the gun is worth someone else's
life they think they don't want to get
their life taken by a home invasion yeah
which does happen did you see that video
of the guy that had a raccoon on his
boat
no he had a raccoon eyes but yeah he saw
any any any no I was a wild raccoon and
he filmed it and he's 20 miles out in
the sea and he sees this raccoon and so
he filmed himself kicking the raccoon
off the boat into the ocean into the
ocean
oh he filmed it and they knew when he
posted it because he had no idea how
ignorant that was he had no idea it was
the raccoon dangerous was it trying to
will [ __ ] you up well [ __ ] you sure sure
but like the what would the wild the
wild guys the wildlife guys said just
get a blanket throw it over put him in
the in the in the bathroom yeah until
you close to shore they kick him off
yeah you know but this guy right away he
freaked it out music this might turn off
my boat towel
well see that's that's the form of
ignorance that that I'm talking about
it's also just fear its fearless that's
what that's what fear is fear is
ignorance right but if someone has a gun
in their house to protect themselves
from home invasions home invasions do
happen and people have saved their
family with guns that that's a real
thing you don't read about that much oh
you read about a plan if you go looking
for it
yeah there's doors if you look at the
the overall there's they have like a pie
chart of gun violence in this country
and an unfortunately large number is
suicides when they start talking about
how many people have died unfortunately
a large number of suicide by gun and I
feel like if people are going to kill
themselves with a gun they'd probably
kill them so the pills or anything else
or they had that as well right
and then there's justifiable homicides
by the police there's there's people
that are protecting their house there's
a bunch of different there's gang
violence there's a bunch of different
things to get lumped in when we talk
about gun violence but a certain
percentage of them are people that are
protecting their house or their help
they're their family from someone who's
trying to hurt them yeah I got that's
happening I'm in business with it with a
with an ex-pilot from Vietnam and I'm
quite sure he has a sidearm in his his
house mm-hm but it would be useless
because it's so locked away and so
hidden by the time anything happened by
the time he got to that gun and got it
loaded and found the army maintainer of
the house
yeah maybe or maybe he could keep it
right by his bed no no in this in this
one instance mhm and then what what if
it's your daughter or something coming
in and late at night and you mistake her
for her while you open your mouth and
say something I also go shooting into
the dark or what if you have homicidal
tendencies and you've been wondering he
sees one thing I learned about guns
because I grew up with guns too I grew
up in the in the country and what's
robbed in Calgary Alberta Canada oh
really oh that's right you're Canadian
you know great so guns guns were about
moving back up there oh no III lived up
there oh no
no no no la is where you want to be but
I grew up with with what guns were yeah
well you actually needed a gun well you
know like especially when the when the
Hawks are coming down to get your
chickens or you know you know some stuff
like that but I seen the gun culture in
in in Calgary and it turned me off
mm-hmm because I sing kids they would
take a stray dog entire him bring him up
to the field time to a tree or something
or post and then shoot him oh Jesus
shoot him yeah that a sport you know and
and they couldn't because here's the
thing about guns oh I went duck hunting
with my brother one time and in the
field and a cup word waiting for the
Ducks to come and so here comes what he
call it's that your phone yeah so
there's your wrist ringing he turned it
off we went duck honey and we're waiting
there for hours where did the Ducks to
come over and my brother he got bored
and there's a muskrat swimming across
the thing so he shot it with his shotgun
and he walks out into the middle of the
the slough picks up the muskrat as the
ducks flew over top of us just stupidity
man that's definitely stupid but there's
responsible gun owners don't you think
well see are like I was an Army Cadets
and when we we had practice I'm a
sharpshooter by the way yeah yeah I got
some some what he called patches you
know a sharpshooter
300 yards so so I know how to handle a
rifle anyway but when we go shooting we
would have to first of all we never got
the weapon and until we march down into
firing position then we're handed the
weapon and one bullet and then we put
the bullet in hit the target and another
bullet shoot the target in a man we were
finished we had to pick up all our
casings
and give them back in if thought
anything was missing no one left until
they found that missing bullet and
that's gun safety yeah then the gun was
taken from us and put it in an armory
it's only used when you're going to use
it you know just like walk around the
skill saw you know you can have a
license to carry a skill saw but you
don't have a skill saw strapped to your
side you can take out and you know try
your skill saw anytime you learn is that
the open carry thing is very strange
when they see people walking around with
guns strapped to their hips in Arizona
you're like okay they're targets why
don't you do that you're in target
anyway yeah it's like the bikers like
bikers you know the Hells Angels and the
Mongols and that they're the only crime
in sin again I know that appetizer back
look at me
yeah look at me I'm gonna thug I'm you
know extort I I do also beat up people I
kill people
Aaron and I write on a big hog you know
it's crazy but people do that for
recognition yeah see that's like mass
shooters that's what they do it for and
get their name in the paper yeah look
what I did
look at but useless old me I'm gonna so
you solution it what's the craziest
thing about mass shooters is this not a
thing I mean guns have been around for a
long time but this is not a thing it's
been around for a long time this is a
fairly recent thing that keeps erupting
over and over and over again I don't
know you were too young to remember but
when I was a kid the crime comics were
banned you're banned they were banned
because you were bad they showed
violence disliked by comic books Wow and
they were people up in arms about comic
books and now you've got video games are
you gonna be a mass killer
well how about movies you know I mean so
many movies all these John wick movies
is everybody's getting shot everybody
yeah I love it one of my favorites -
peppermint with peppermint what's up
is Jennifer Gardner oh she's a superhero
Oh or her name is pepper man the
the name of the movie is peppermint have
you heard of Sammy yeah um
Malik must eight months that's great but
I watched about three times now and in
the lats yeah
well have you watched it so many times I
think Jennifer garden is kind of hot
oh and and this year I see her to see
her with the guns in her and the third
time I realized a lot of it we're stunt
stunt people how can you tell
just I seen it so many times it wasn't
okay so you're looking for everything
yeah I'm the little thing but again
that's the kind of violence said that we
we get on and people get an immune yes
especially especially people they get
stupid you know
like when I was a kid I saw pitch my
brother died recently and there's a
whole picture photo thing of him and I
when we were kids and they used to get
put under the Christmas tree six guns
and we're when we're little guys we we
were those three or four years old I had
six can strap to my myself you know
because cowboy Rogers and gene Audrey
and that was a big deal you know you had
your six guns but you never shot anybody
you just shut the gun under their hand
yeah that was the old days you know
right the good guys always shot people
in the hand they shot the gun away from
them world